so one of the things we did we've done
over the 30 years of being on the air is
when we find a problem that you guys
have
we don't necessarily need to get in
those businesses
we just help someone that's already in
those businesses help you
if they're reputable and they have the
solution to your problem but i was
getting all these calls for
20 years dave i can't get out of my
timeshare i can't sell it i can't get
them to
call them i can't talk them into it i've
offered to pay them to take it back they
won't
i've offered to sell it i've offered i
can't get i can't donate it to charity i
can't get rid of it i'm stuck
so these two young guys call us and they
had started a
time share exit company called timeshare
exit team
and it was on a couple of radio stations
it was doing pretty well around america
and they said they won't be on the dave
ramsey show and i go
guys when i put you on here and i say
you can get people out of time shares
your business is going to explode
exponentially well that's what we want i
said yeah but can you handle all those
phone calls can you handle all those
cases can you get all this work done
because you know you can't take all this
business on and not take care of these
people
well i was wrong it didn't explode it
exploded i mean it was amazing
and these poor guys they they were they
they were getting people out of time
shares left and right left and right
left and right left and right
but they couldn't hire fast enough they
couldn't keep up with the phone calls
they couldn't keep up
and every time we would get complaints
because somebody wouldn't get their
phone call returned or something we get
on them
and they say i know we're hiring and
we're doing this and we even sent them
some of our leadership training
so they could grow their businesses so
that they could get the job
done to get you people out of your time
shares
they got over 20 000 people out of
timeshares
and they were one of the most successful
timeshare comp exit companies in america
they weren't the first they weren't even
probably the best but they were very
successful
uh we sent them a lot of volume
obviously uh
but they grew they outgrew their ability
to return phone calls and get everything
done
they ended up just they got overwhelmed
because it was so stinking popular
because people
hate time shares so the timeshare
companies
decide to target them and start suing
them
and banding together and suing them and
mike flasky got up and stood in front of
the timeshare association
word is i haven't found the actual
transcript yet but we've heard from
bloggers in the industry
that he stood up and said he's going to
pledge that the industry is pledging
50 million dollars to put anybody in the
timeshare exit business out of business
if they were going to sue them until
they ran them out of business and so
they started suing
timeshare exit team over and over and
over and over again then they talk
the uh uh attorney general over in
washington state into going after them
i've yet to figure out how that happens
a little more to come on that later i
promise you i'm just still investigating
that
uh and he's trying to depose me which is
funny
uh and man i mean this has been a these
companies are trying to
depose me because i endorsed them of
course i endorsed them
they got 20 000 people other time shares
but they've now been overwhelmed with
legal fees
and so they're no longer on the air with
us because they're spending all
of their money trying to stay alive in
these legal battles
and so now i don't know i can't figure
out how the timeshare business
they have so much money they just buy
their way into everything or intimidate
their way into everything
apparently because then inside edition
which is a
well-known what piece of crap tabloid
thing right uh decides they're going to
do a thing on
timeshare exit team and they're going to
do a thing on me because i endorse them
but timeshare exit teams ripping people
off you got it wrong inside edition
timeshare exit team isn't who's ripping
people off it's the timeshare companies
that ripping people off
so poor little poor little dumb lisa
guerrero
with uh inside edition decided she's
going to do a story so she calls us and
of course we ignore her because they're
doing a hit piece and you don't
participate in your own hit piece it's a
ruling
media and i'm a public figure so why am
i going to give you information to do a
hit piece on me that's just dumb
i'm not so just jump in the creek
besides that you're inside addition
you're a tabloid
and little lisa guerrero i mean
everybody kind of knows about her she's
kind of a laughingstock she
was on monday night football for a whole
year uh this is back in the 2000s abc
sports dismissed lisa guerrero from her
job as sideline
reporter on monday night football a
position she held for just one season
she came to abc from fox sports with
limited
sports broadcasting experience yeah you
think she'll be replaced by michelle
tafolla
and a lead sideline reporter for abc and
espn her freshman season on monday night
football was filled with
awkward moments and competence mistakes
and most notably after the reagan's
regular season opening
between the jets and the washington
redskins a stumbled
interview with patrick ramsey she could
not improve she was incompetent
dumb and they fired her off monday night
football so now she's a star reporter on
inside edition
so she attacks me in the lobby
a week and a half ago of the omni in
dallas while we're there doing our
entree leadership event ambushes you
know one of these ambush things where
they pop out
with the microphone start running along
trying to get the comment and all this
stuff
and i'm walking with one of my team
members along and uh
he steps between us and
she is whacking him with her arm
trying to push him out of the way to get
to me
and now she goes on instagram and says
we attacked her and her arm is bruised
so lisa we have the omni security
footage
and we've broken it down frame by frame
and sweet girl here's how it works you
will not hurt your arm if you don't hit
people with
it you were not
attacked you were the attacker and any
of you that have seen the bruises on her
forearm
these are the bruises of someone that is
aggressively attacking someone not
someone who is
being attacked you don't get a bruise
across the whole front of your forearm
when you're attacked
that's when you're hitting someone that
that happens
and you go on national television and
say dave ramsey's goons beat you
up you poor stupid little girl
i think maybe the way you hurt your arm
is when you got in bed with the
timeshare people
that might have been when you hurt your
arm
that's very possible something for you
guys to think about out there
so this is how this stuff works out here
when you deal with these multi-billion
dollar
companies multi-billion dollar companies
will put failed sideline reporters from
inside edition
on you an on-time share exit team and
put dave ramsey up as if he somehow
endorsed somebody he shouldn't have
endorsed
was timeshare exit team perfect
absolutely not
absolutely not they took on too much
business
they couldn't return everybody's phone
calls they did not do a stellar job
and we talked to them about it several
times we were trying to work with them
and trying to work their way through it
but basically they have been hammered
now
by legal fees and they can no longer you
know afford to be on the dave ramsey
show to provide the service
to get you people out of a timeshare
because they're spending all of their
bandwidth
fighting with these bozos
people like david siegel
and you know the princess of versailles
right
oh my god or mikey flasky who just got i
don't know how much money from this
hilton sale
diamond bought by hilton hilton you have
a real problem
you've just damaged your brand you took
on one of the most grotesque
brands in all of timeshare one of the
most horrendous
group of people lack of character
anywhere
and you made them part of hilton you
guys
really just screwed up and you gave them
1.4 billion dollars and they screw
people
left and right every day there's
comments all over the internet
the the attorney general shuts them down
gets an
800 000 fine
against them in the city in the state of
arizona
and we just heard several diamond
testimonies here on the air from people
who tried to deal with diamond or got
screwed by diamond
or any of these other things so this is
how this works you guys
so here's the thing
not many people get the opportunity to
hit back on
pieces of crap in the press when they do
a bad job
i happen to have a platform that allows
me to tell you people what really
happened
and what the real truth is so inside
edition
in case you didn't figure it out you
suck